we have entered day three of the liberal
freakout over the potential overruling
of Roe versus Wade very few of the
sounds and shrieks that the Liberals are
making even vaguely resemble arguments
but one guttural moan in particular that
I heard while still not constituting an
argument did get to the heart of the
issue this came from Anna kasparian at
The Young Turks these comments might be
strong but it's how I genuinely feel
um I don't care that you're a Christian
I don't care what the Bible says like I
feel like it's a clown show like sitting
here trying to decipher what your little
mythical book has to say about these
very real political issues right I don't
care if you're Christian in fact I will
fight for you to have your religious
liberty and practice your Christianity I
believe in that I don't believe in
Christianity which means that you do not
get to dictate the way I live my life
based on your religion I don't care what
the Bible says you have every right in
the world all those women who identify
with your religion have every right in
the world to not get an abortion to not
take birth control but they do not have
the right to dictate my life and what I
decide to do with my body I don't care
about your goddamn religion
Anna doesn't care about our religion
Anna doesn't care what we believe and I
think she is expressing the actual view
of what the left what the left thinks
here the thing is
I don't care what she believes about
this I don't care what she believes
about abortion about infanticide on a
separate issue I don't care what she
thinks about transgenderism I don't care
and she doesn't get to force those views
on me just because she really really
wants to
we live in a political Community we get
to persuade one another of our views I
think that my view is correct on
abortion on transgenderism on all sorts
of other issues and so we're going to
persuade one another and we're going to
have standards and we're going to decide
how to live together in a political
Community within the bounds of the
Constitution that's how this works so
you can scream and yell and say me me I
want it my way that's not the way
government works that's not the way
politics works we have a political
community and limits called the
Constitution and there is simply no
question whatever you think about
abortion or anything else there is
simply no question there is no right to
abortion in the Constitution I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
foreign
comment yesterday is from mikey79 who
says when we are told abortion is
Reproductive Rights I just want to ask
them well what are you reproducing right
the very word it's it's an ironic term
Reproductive Rights because of course
abortion is not a right and it it
results in the opposite of reproduction
the very fact that one is acknowledging
that this is about reproduction tells
you that there is a baby present and the
baby has certain rights and you don't
just have the right to kill the baby we
have a guest coming up who is going to
articulate the pro-abortion side of this
issue because look we don't want to
knock down Straw Men all right first
though you got to text Knowles to 98 98
98 finally happened the FED is realizing
the Dire Straits that our economy is in
thanks to our loose monetary policy
turns out you can't just spend trillions
of dollars every year with no
repercussions now to play catch-up the
FED has been raising rates and plans to
seven times this year your already
starting to see those Ripple effects in
the housing market as people's buying
power diminishes have you considered
what could happen in the stock market
if our economy stalls out do not wait
till that happens take some of your
profits from the stock market now
solidify them with gold from Birch gold
threat history gold has maintained its
value better than any other investment
in the world
text Knowles kwles to 98 98 98 for a
free zero obligation info kit on holding
gold in a tax sheltered retirement
account join the thousands of happy
Birch gold customers with countless
five-star reviews and an A plus rating
from the Better Business Bureau I trust
the professionals at Birch gold text
Knolls Canon wlas to 98 9898 secure the
gains that you've made while you still
can we don't want to just be talking in
an echo chamber here we don't want to be
pyromaniacs in a field of straw man and
so we we sometimes invite left Wingers
on the show to present the strongest
version of their point of view I'm
always very grateful when left Wingers
come on the show not an easy thing to do
most most of them just refuse to do it
so I'm very pleased that our guest is
Bronte remzick who is a third year
medical student a social activist very
much in support of legal abortion we've
gone back and forth on Tick Tock and
Twitter and Myspace and all sorts of
social media platforms so we thought
let's just have her on the show and
discuss the issue Bronte thank you so
much for coming coming on
hi Michael I can't say that it's a
pleasure but I'm excited to help you
expand your perspective well that's very
kind of you to do that so Bronte before
we get to the issue of abortion itself
which I suspect we will get to I guess
we have to get to this issue that Anna
kasparian raised and that is really at
the heart of this Supreme Court decision
in the past week of the news cycle
namely does the Constitution enshrine a
right to abortion it seems very
difficult to argue that it does one
because I don't see that right anywhere
the judges who decided that there was a
right in 1973 a right that previously
had never been acknowledged in the
Constitution they said that it was found
within the emanations and the penumbras
and they couldn't quite point to exactly
where it was but hey anyway it's there
then you had planned parenthood V Casey
in the early 1990s which actually
overruled part of Roe versus Wade at
least in the argument for why we needed
legal abortion but nevertheless upheld
legal abortion and it was all kind of
just a big jumbled mess so is it your
position that the constitution provides
for some heretofore invisible right to
an abortion regardless of what you think
about the issue
it is my opinion that we have a right to
privacy and abortion is a medical
procedure and the right to privacy does
extend to the discussions between a
patient and a medical provider okay but
I could have a right to privacy with my
Mafia coppo and we could decide to whack
my political enemy and those I guess
those conversations would be private I
don't think there is some generalized
right to privacy in the Constitution but
even if they were that would have no
bearing on the life of the person that
we're going to kill right
well the discussion between you and your
mafia friend is very different from a
discussion between a patient and a
medical provider we have laws that
protect patient privacy for this exact
reason but but I suppose you're right
the distinction is that right now it's
illegal for me to talk to my mafia boss
and call out a hit on someone I don't
like and it is legal right now at least
according to the civil law for a woman
to talk to a doctor and kill her child
but that very likely will not remain
legal if Roe versus weight is overturned
in 13 14 States instantly that will
become illegal so I guess I'm just
talking about the matter itself Beyond
questions of the civil law which might
be changing in real time right now
what's the difference if if you're
saying it's all about a right to privacy
I'm saying No it's it's about the baby
that's being killed so do you have an
answer for that or are we just denying
the humanity of the baby no absolutely
so when you put up a scenario of trying
to put out a hit with the mafia you are
talking about murdering a born living
conscious sentient person when we talk
about abortion we are talking about
ending a non-autonomous life it does you
do not have the right to bodily autonomy
if you are not autonomous and if you are
a fetus prior to the limit of viability
you do not have autonomy therefore you
do not have the right to bodily autonomy
this is a great point you reside inside
of the body of an autonomous person and
the right to bottle the autonomy allows
you to refuse to use your body to
support the life of another person so
this is a precise and important point
you've made you've acknowledged that
abortion ends a life but you've said
those were your exact words you just
said that the life is not autonomous
would you say that a two-day-old
post-birth baby is autonomous
it is it has bodily autonomy and it's
able its body system is able to function
autonomously yes the baby can feed
itself you are trying to get to the
point where they require external
resources but any person can provide
that infant external resources the
utilization of someone's internal organs
is very different from providing
external resources you cannot force
someone to be a parent and provide
external resources you can give up that
child at any point that you stop
consenting to your parental
responsibilities in your parental right
okay so so this that's fine so so we've
acknowledged now that the baby is is
living in the womb or outside the womb
it's a living being and that the baby is
is not really autonomous maybe it has it
it's not attached by an umbilical cord
but it certainly doesn't have autonomy
when it's two days old it needs it needs
to eat it needs everything taken care of
for it what you're saying is though once
the umbilical cord has been severed the
baby can be taken care of by someone
else so then my question is
why would we not merely encourage
adoption if the mother feels she can't
take care of the baby why not just give
up the baby for adoption rather than
killing the baby in the womb
his pregnancy in itself is a very
serious medical condition that has
physical mental emotional and financial
burdens for the pregnant person and to
force a person to endure that experience
against their will is simply immoral and
it's belittling the experience that
pregnancy is well so when you say
against their will what you are you're
referring to cases of rape basically
right because when you engage in sex you
are engaging in an act of the will the
consequence of which is historically
speaking always pregnancy
correct but when you consent to sex
you're not consenting to pregnancy you
are consenting to the possibility of
pregnancy but you can think of it like
this you can think of it like this you
understand the difference between
consensual sex and sexual sexual assault
you should then understand the
difference between wanted pregnancy and
unwanted pregnancy technically
physically they are the same thing but
when your body is being used against
your will and without your consent those
are very different experiences for the
person but Bronte you you've just
acknowledged that when you consent to
sex you are consenting to the
possibility of pregnancy so there you
have it there you are you have consented
to that now you might not want to become
pregnant you might want to use all sorts
of contraceptives and things like that
but surely I mean you've just said it
yourself you're consenting to that
possibility and so now you're telling me
that if one wants to then withdraw one's
consent because one doesn't want to be
uncomfortable for some matter of months
you're saying that the the better
alternative is to just kill the baby
whom you have acknowledged is alive
first of all calling pregnancy simply
discomfort is belittling the experience
but you can also think it's beautiful
and miraculous too but it's also
uncomfortable it's the white man who
will never experience it I can think of
it no so I thought that can can men
become pregnant or no
if you have a uterus
yeah a man with a uterus Michael so if
you don't have a uterus then you're not
the men with her well look I'm not a
biologist so I'm not sure if I'll become
pregnant I do have a little emoji that
tells me that these days men can become
pregnant regardless regardless of that
if you're talking about non-consensual
sex what percentage of pregnancies arise
from rape incest or involve a threat to
the life of the mother well it's hard to
say because about three quarters of
sexual assault go unreported so any
statistic that I would give to you is
going to be inherently an actor I'll
give you a statistic a statistic from
the most left-wing Source I can give the
gutmacher Institute is the think tank
for Planned Parenthood less than one
percent of abortions take place because
of rape incestors propose a threat to
the life of the mother so we're talking
about it accordingly the ones that have
been reported according to the ones that
have been reported don't you think don't
you think there were don't you think if
there were a scarier statistic that the
most pro-abortion organization in the
country might use those statistics
are very difficult to collect
again sexual assault is a difficult
issue when people don't often report
them because you see how our political
system doesn't often support victims of
sexual assault and so our system doesn't
support people reporting sexual assault
therefore it is underreported so this
seems difficult for me Bronte well one
it seems that in the years after the
metoo movement there was quite a great
political impulse to report sexual
assault and all sorts of sexual issues
but furthermore you're telling me that
we need to rely on these statistics
trust the science trust the public
health organizations when it's
convenient for your argument and
convenient for abortion but we shouldn't
trust this Statistics when it's
inconvenient for your argument argument
and supports the pro-life argument that
is incorrect you simply don't understand
how these statistics work and how they
are collected when you understand when
you analyze statistics you have to
understand the bias and the flaws that
they have and what you are specifically
citing statistics that have inherent
flaws that doesn't mean that all of the
statistics that we cite are inherently
flawed you have to understand the issue
at hand and how those statistics are
collected okay fair enough so so you're
saying you just you don't believe these
statistics that are inconvenient but you
say you have perfectly good reason not
to believe the statistics I suppose the
question though is really beyond the
statistics isn't it if you are
acknowledging Bronte that the baby is
alive if you are acknowledging that the
baby could be given up for adoption if
you are acknowledging that instances of
rape are I think we can acknowledge
they're quite rare at least when we're
talking about even if you dispute some
of the statistics there there are the
exception not the rule if you are
acknowledging all sorts of if you're
acknowledging the relatively low
maternal mortality rate if you are
acknowledging the advancements in
science if you are acknowledging that
very very few women die every year from
illegal abortions and all sorts of the
the other scare statistics that come out
if you're acknowledging all of those
numbers even beyond that
don't don't we still have the fact of
the baby don't we still have the
non-utilitarian non-statistical simple
fact that you're talking about a living
human being
no so first off you said that we have a
low mortality rate which actually we
have one of the highest maternal
mortality rates amongst all of the
developed countries but it's still quite
like what's what is the maternal
mortality right according to the city
you know it off the top of my head 20
out of 20 out of 100 000 and that and
that includes communities that do not
have very good Public Health outcomes
because of various behaviors and
pathologies in the community so it's
relatively quite low how many women died
from illegal abortion the year before
Roe versus Wade
I'm not sure but that's besides the
point 39 women how many women die from
legal abortion the year before Roe
versus Wade
is that death is not the only negative
outcome of pregnancy just because you
don't die does not mean that your life
and your body is not impacted for the
rest of your life because a lot of
people are left with chronic pain and
your body is functionally and
structurally altered and so death is not
the most accurate statistic to determine
whether or not pregnancy is a negative
experience there there we go so so we we
move past the question of death and we
say well really it's forget about death
for a second it's just that it's it's
very uncomfortable and not only
uncomfortable for nine months it might
be uncomfortable for the rest of your
life or it might change your body
chemistry it might change the way you
look or it might change is any of that
I'll leave you with this because I know
we're way over the time is any of that
an argument now that we've kind of
chipped away I I think at least it's up
for the viewers to decide chipped away
at the Constitutional argument or the
legal argument or the statistical
argument or the argument for mortality
now we get down to well it's just I just
don't like what it does to my body is
that an argument for killing a human
being who you admit is alive
absolutely everyone has the right to
determine you
how their body is used and if you would
like to go back to I know that you've
had a lot to say about vaccines and
masks so I don't think it's very
confusing for you to understand when you
are concerned about certain effects that
certain things might have on your body
someone has every right to decide
whether or not they consent to that well
my only issue with the masks and all the
covid stuff is that it's very silly and
disordered but I'm not not even making
some sort of maximal bodily autonomy
argument regardless though I think
they're a little different because we're
acknowledging the baby so so I would I
guess I would leave you with this
thought from Naomi wolf uh well
well-known feminist uh made this point
in the 1990s she said that what the
pro-abortion movement needs to be able
to do is defend abortion and she was and
I think still may be a defender of
abortion she said we need to defend
abortion by acknowledging the baby the
unborn baby we need to say that the
unborn baby is a baby stop pretending
he's not a human stop pretending he's
not alive acknowledge that he's a baby
and say that for women to be equal they
must be able to kill the baby in all of
his Humanity would you agree with that
statement
what I agree with is that in order to
protect and value an unborn non-viable
non-sentient life
actively devalue and dehumanize the
pregnant person you cannot pretend to
protect unborn life without actively
dehumanizing and devaluing the pregnant
person and removing their bodily
autonomy and that is the issue at hand
it seems to me when we treat women as
mothers we are valuing them it's I don't
think it's I think it's devaluing women
to use them for sex and try to avoid the
consequences of sex by killing the baby
and then pretending it's somehow
legitimate because the baby is not
sentient so as though we could kill
someone in a coma or is there someone
who were asleep the baby were not
particularly conscious as though we
could kill people who had mental
disabilities I don't think any of those
arguments really work and I think I
think the issue that's at heart here is
that you are suggesting that women being
used as vessels for sexual pleasure
without dealing with the consequences of
sex namely the creation of human beings
that that is somehow more liberating and
more empowering than women coming
together uh in love and giving that love
with a man to a human being I think
that's when it really comes down I find
it interesting that whenever you talk
about women having sex you say that we
are used and that proves the fact no not
whenever not whenever only no no only in
your version of it not not in I don't
think women should be used for sexual
incorrect it does it seems like men
still believe that sex is something that
they do to women and not no no you must
have misheard me Bronte I said that men
and women no I I don't think I did but
that's up for the listeners to decide I
said that the the more valuing
liberating flourishing if you have sex
is that men and women come together
because they are complementary they love
one another they join together in
marriage and they create new human life
and that's a beautiful miraculous
wonderful thing and I think that the
view of the pro-abortion movement is
that women
ought to be used as a merely vessels for
sexual pleasure with with and out of
accountability such that if there is a
product of Love or maybe not so much
love namely a child that comes out of
that sexual Union that that baby ought
to be killed I think that's a devaluing
of women rather than evaluing or a
liberation
minimizing women's value to the role of
motherhood is simply misogynistic
minimizing I think that's maximizing
frankly I think yeah I think the
universe world view which is obviously
flawed well I don't know we were both
born of mothers and I'm quite happy for
that value that was added to my life and
I'm very happy that my mother consented
to the pregnancy that brought meet
fourth but I would never want my mother
to bring me into the world against her
will
all right I I mean yeah I don't think
that uh I don't think our discussion of
will or value or any of those things I
I think it has boiled down to this this
particular point of of what the body is
for right I mean isn't that kind of what
we're talking about here is is our body
for is sex for the maximal individual
pursuit of pleasure or is it for
something else is it for a baby is it
for uh unit of Love is it for something
Beyond just our own desires
your body is whatever you want it to be
used for that is the basis of consent
and bodily autonomy you cannot decide
what the use and value of someone's body
is for them and that is the root of the
pro-choice dance what about the what
about the body of the baby in in the
abortion when you decide maybe when the
baby lacks autonomy and it requires the
body of an autonomous person in order to
live that autonomous person must
exercise their bodily autonomy and at
any point they must consent to
supporting that possible life must
exercise all right I'm way over as usual
Bronte but I listen I really appreciate
your coming on uh it's uh takes takes a
lot of hutzpah I know there's a lot of
sexual confusion these days but it takes
kahones to come on a conservative show
and discuss the issue I I hope that uh
as you think about this issue and stew
on it some more that uh your eyes are
opened to the reality of the situation
but I I appreciate your coming on in any
case Bronte Remick where can people find
you
absolutely they can find me on Tick Tock
at Bronte remzick I also have my website
is be kind and curious.com all right
thank you Bronte appreciate it now
now that we have solved the issues of
the world and resolved the most pressing
uh political problem in the entire
country when we're talking about proper
uses of autonomy we ought to do things
ourselves on our own automobiles which
is why you've got to check out
rockauto.com right now head on over to
rockauto.com enter Knolls in their
headed your Betis box so they know that
we sent you the value of the minivan
pickup sedan or whatever you drive
probably appreciated significantly this
year so take care of your Automotive
investment keep more of your money by
buying the auto parts you need to
maintain and repair your vehicle at
rockauto.com okay rockauto.com it's
going to save you the time of driving to
the brick and mortar auto parts store
then standing in line then waiting to
see if they have the part then they
don't have the part then you drive back
then you got to go back a week later
then they have why would you do any of
that you can save twenty percent thirty
percent fifty percent
for the very same Parts online same
prices for pros and do-it-yourselfers no
gimmicks no nothing like that you're
just going to rockauto.com right now for
your Auto Parts these guys have been
supporters of the show from the very
beginning we love them most importantly
make sure you write Knowles k o w l e s
in there how did you hear about this box
so they know that we sent you that is a
rockauto.com
you can thank me later
the the I'm really glad Bronte came on
the show that uh
she didn't quite go all the way to the
Naomi wolf statement but I think she
expressed that view which is yeah I was
afraid that Bronte was going to say no
it's not a baby no he's not alive no it
doesn't really matter
but Bronte said no the baby is alive
it's just that for women to be equal we
need to we need to be able to kill the
baby it's a ghastly argument but I am
glad that she took it beyond beyond the
issue of
even consent
right she took it Beyond she just said
no this is an act of this is an act of
the will that I am going to force onto
my baby and I'm willing to stand by it
it's ghastly but it uh it's a little
more honest than a lot of the
pro-abortion arguments that one
typically hears
it seems to me her the weakest part of
her argument was on the Constitution
because she said well there's some
general right to privacy we have no idea
where it is but don't worry it's
somewhere we'll find it somewhere and uh
so uh that's why you have the right to
an abortion that that doesn't really
hold water Roe versus Wade held uh that
you could kill a baby based on a
trimester system this was partially
overruled in Planned Parenthood by Casey
in 1992 and it replaced the trimester
system with a viability system so once
the baby is viable then you can have
restrictions on abortion but even
viability is very difficult because
modern medical technology has moved that
scale so far back that that viability is
always going to be a moving Target
now the Dobbs case is deciding whether
or not there's a right to an abortion at
all I don't think there is but there
there are two two arguments that the
conservatives can make and the
pro-lifers can make here one is that
it's the sort of uh Scalia argument that
abortion is simply not mentioned in the
Constitution this is an issue for the
legislatures this is an issue for the
states there is a stronger argument I
think which was recently pushed by the
legal Scholars John finis and Robbie
George who argued in a brief on the
Dobbs case that actually the Supreme
Court does have a right to determine
abortion policy because the 14th
Amendment to the United States
Constitution prohibits abortion
and the reason for that is that people
have equal protection under the laws and
they make a really strong argument that
that even even the phrase
born persons refer to babies who have
not yet been born and the argument for
this goes back to blackstones
commentaries probably the most famous
Treatise on the English common law
published before the American Revolution
which says explicitly that babies in the
mother's womb are for all intents and
purposes of the law already born and we
know that this was in the minds of the
people who were writing the 14th
Amendment because the 14th Amendment is
based on the Civil Rights Act of 1866
and you see in the debates regarding the
Civil Rights Act of 1866 you see direct
references to this sort of thing in
Blackstone and elsewhere so it we don't
need a crystal ball you don't need to
take out your nullstradamus hat to think
well what did the framers really mean
what do these words really mean we
actually know there's a lot of writing
and a lot of debate on the issue
that would be a stronger argument
regardless though
the argument that seems to have won the
day if the Alito case is or the Alito
opinion in the court is legitimate which
it would appear to be is that the issue
is going to go back to the states and
the issue is going to go back to the
legislatures and so it's not the end of
the pro-life movement really it's only
the very beginning
this is going to get much more heated
much more hot we can go back to Anna
kasparian on on The Young Turks who made
another not legal not scientific not
MediCal argument but another
emotional plea as to why we should have
legal abortion we don't even have paid
family leave we don't even have
affordable child care in this freaking
country
okay and the people who fight against
those kinds of laws are
Owens
and yet what do you want them to do
what do you
watching and
question ask them ask them
isn't it amazing to ask them the goddamn
question
God okay I'll answer and I'll answer the
question it's okay what do you want
mothers to do with their kids raise them
that would be one idea what do you want
mothers to do with their kids yeah they
could raise their kids would be one
option
but what about when they go to work well
I ideally they could stay home and their
their husbands could could go to work
and I D I know that that's difficult
these days because the way the economy
has been restructured well ideally
hopefully we can we can rework the
American economy such that you can
support a family on one income that
would be my ideal solution and Blake
Master is running in Arizona is calling
for that sort of thing JD Vance the
Senate candidate who just won the Ohio
GOP Primary he's calling for that sort
of thing we had that for a long time in
this country that would be a solution to
that question
well what are we what about single
mothers well we could discourage divorce
and we could encourage marriage what are
we going to do what if you just what if
you just can't raise the kid you don't
feel you're capable well you could you
could give the kid up for adoption
you could do literally anything else
other than kill the kid
right how about we try that
there's simple answers to this you don't
need to get all heated and angry and
emotional very often when people get
heated and angry and emotional it shows
that they don't have a very solid grasp
on the situation but what the libs are
so Furious about this that they're going
to upend all sorts of norms and
traditions you know right now our
economy is very upended which is why
you've got to check out Alto Ira right
now go to Alto ira.com Michael do you
have an account with coinbase are you
thinking of opening one with an alto
crypto Ira you can trade crypto like
Bitcoin and avoid or defer taxes very
important get into investing in crypto
and do it in a tax advantage retirement
account trade all you want without the
tax headache create an account in just a
few minutes and invest with as little as
10 bucks no setup charges there are 150
plus coins available including Bitcoin
ethereum cardano you want some sushi
swap with your Bitcoin no problem Alto
has you covered they have industry
leading security the advanced encryption
standard for wallets and private Keys
plus there are multiple ways to fund
your account make a cash contribution
transfer cash from an existing Ira or
roll over an old 401k
open that Alto crypto IRA account today
with as little as 10 bucks go to
altoira.com Michael
start investing in cryptocurrency today
that is Alto ira.com Michael
jensaki speaking on behalf of the
president
she was asked will Joe Biden accept a
supreme court opinion that overrules Roe
versus weight and overrules Planned
Parenthood V Casey and jensaki didn't
quite answer
if the Supreme Court does move to strike
down row should Americans be prepared to
this accept that decision as legitimate
and would President Biden accept that
decision as legitimate well I can't
speak for what actions could be possible
on the legal front I would point to the
Department of Justice on that but what I
can tell you will happen is and this is
what we are preparing for the
possibility of that if roe were to fall
abortion would probably be illegal in
about half the states in the country up
to 26 States particularly in the South
the Midwest and West it sounds like
you're saying then that's a yes he would
consider this a legitimate decision well
there is not even a decision yet we
don't know the validity of the we know
that this is a leaked document it is not
the final opinion so I just can't speak
to that hypothetically at this point in
time
of course you can speak to that what are
you talking about it's a leaked opinion
it's a it's an opinion that everyone has
been expecting for a long time which is
that the Supreme Court has overruled Roe
versus Wade will the president accept
that well I just I don't know I can't
even imagine that what are you talking
about you Democrats have been
fundraising on this for 50 years on the
threat of overruling Roe versus Wade
you you certainly can imagine that it's
a very simple answer yes the president
respects the Supreme Court yes the
president respects the separation of
powers and our constitutional structure
and our democracy oh wait a second no
you don't respect any of that stuff when
it's not convenient for you I never want
to hear it again I never want to hear
about January 6th and our sacred
democracy when you walk into the capital
the sacred Temple of you don't believe
any of that crap you don't believe that
for one second
because the the moment that the Supreme
Court
rightly upholds and interprets the
Constitution you suggest yeah we're not
going to do that it it reminds me of of
the Democrats who made such a big fuss
about getting Donald Trump to say that
he would accept the results of the 2016
presidential election and then he won
and the Democrats didn't accept the
results of the 2016 election that's what
we're talking about
so transparent by the way we're getting
more wins from the Supreme Court there's
a big win just came out uh totally
separate from the abortion issue this
was on the first amendment there was a
case in in Boston over at the Boston
City Hall there are multiple flagpoles
that are standing there and one of the
flagpoles is open to fly various Flags
the community wants to put up and so
they put all sorts of flags up there and
a Christian group wanted to fly a flag
and a Boston City Hall said absolutely
not you can't do that
the Supreme Court just ruled that that
was a violation of the Christian group's
First Amendment rights the city had
already approved more than 280 flag
raisings over a dozen years they only
rejected one and that was Camp
Constitution's Christian flag
so this was a unanimous Supreme Court
decision even the libs went went on with
this and said no you can't you can't
just single out the Christians and say
that you don't get speech but every
other group in in the country does get
speech this is a really good opinion and
actually Justice Stephen Breyer who's a
liberal Justice on the court he even got
a snarky little comment in there about
how ugly Boston City Hall is so he said
that uh the flagpole at issue stands at
the entrance of Boston City Hall built
in the late 1960s Boston City Hall is a
raw concrete structure an example of the
brutalist style critics of the day
heralded it as a public building that
articulates its functions with strength
dignity Grace and even glamor the design
has since proved somewhat more
controversial uh see Boston City Hall
named world's ugliest building
which is true it is one of the ugliest
buildings in the world so I this was
generally speaking a wonderful decision
for conservatives for Christians and yet
I knew
I know even as I read this I knew
putting my my little Nostradamus hat on
taking on my crystal ball I knew this is
going to be used by the satanists
they and not not two days later
the satanists come out and they say that
they want to raise their flag at City
Hall
and uh the leader or the co-founder of
the satanic temple says religious
liberty is a Bedrock principle in a
democracy and religious liberty is
dependent upon government Viewpoint
neutrality therefore we want to raise
the satanic flag over City Hall
this is going to split people even on
the right the hardcore libertarian types
are probably going to say yeah let the
satanists raise their flag Viewpoint
neutrality man and the conservative
people are going to say no no we're not
we're not going to tolerate Satanist
flags flying above City Hall
so who's right
well according to the principle that the
Satanist articulated
any flag should fly right he said that
we need Viewpoint neutrality the
government cannot have any views on any
matter whatsoever it's the same thing
that Anna kasparian was articulating at
the top of the show I don't I I hate
Christianity and I'm not a Christian but
but you can have your Christianity just
don't impose it on me
she says as she's imposing her views on
us that's the that's the Satanist
position Viewpoint neutrality
conservatives know
there's no such thing as neutrality
first of all here's a little history
check here's a good rule of thumb what
would Washington do what would the
founding fathers do What Would The Men
Who Built our country do do you think
they would they would exalt the raising
of a satanic flag as the high point of
the blessing of liberty no I don't think
so I think they would run the satanists
out of town on a rail and they would
they would probably Deport them from the
country
so no so what happened how did we end up
in this spot well the view that that
this guy articulated Viewpoint
neutrality uh comes uh in recent years
from a 1995 Supreme Court case Rosenberg
versus rectors and visitors of the
University of Virginia uh this this case
is really the beginning of our national
obsession with Viewpoint neutrality and
and conservatives and Christians have
have really embraced this idea of
viewpoint neutrality because at the
moment it's protecting religious people
or it seems to be protecting religious
people from the predations of an atheist
culture but it's a silly idea there is
of course there's no neutrality of
course there is no of course a political
Community has the right and the
obligation to say that some things are
good and some things are bad every
political community in the history of
the world has held something sacred and
and held other things taboo there's no
avoiding that we can bury our heads in
the sand and pretend otherwise but
that's not the case we have sacred
images today unfortunately the sacred
images in our country are the pride flag
the sacred images are the face of George
Floyd The Sacred images but we have them
and we have a whole Liturgical Calendar
we have a culture and we have ultimately
religious views that must be held
because all politics ultimately comes
down to religion whether Anna kasparian
or the head of the satanic temple want
to admit it or not okay we're talking
about important things here folks life
and death you are going to die which is
why you need a will which is why you
need to go check out epic will right now
go to epicwill.com use promo code
Knowles do you know what I did yesterday
I made my will that's actually what I
did just yesterday if something should
happen to you or your spouse who do you
trust to raise your kids the way that
you want them to be raised who do you
trust to take care of your business to
take care of the things you're leaving
behind okay if you do not have a will in
place you have no say in the future of
your children that's a crazy thought if
you're single and don't think you need a
will you could not be more wrong a will
allows you to establish advance
directive medical power of attorney
you really want to leave the burden of
deciding life support or not to your
family members or close friends no a
will will allow you to clearly
communicate to your loved ones what your
wishes are regarding your health if you
haven't made one yet you're not alone
we're going to make it easy for you at
epicwill.com when you use promo code
Knowles we are so excited that they are
partnering with us at the daily wire
they're protecting our staff and our
families let them protect yours
epicwill.com promo code nulls that's how
easy it is secure your future in as
little as five minutes complete package
starts at just 119 bucks promo code
knows you'll save 10 percent
epicwill.com the most important five
minutes you will spend today
when you look at our culture all around
us you'll notice that it is reflecting
everything except for what we believe so
it's time to build our own culture
that's what we're doing here at the
daily wire we're taking on Hollywood
we're taking out razor companies that
cave to the woke we're taking on the
publishing industry we're taking on
Disney okay stop giving your money to
organizations that don't respect you or
your values help us build Alternatives
where the left is tearing down
Foundation foundations start today head
over to dailywire.com subscribe use code
Knowles for 20 off your new membership
join us in our fight to preserve real
American values today we'll be right
back with a lot more
foreign
speaking of demonic activity the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
Xavier Becerra
is now publicly defending irreversible
sex mutilation for children
could you explain
what irreversible top and bottom sex
change surgeries are and why that is on
the portal as well
Senator there as you've just indicated
there are many different uh types of
procedures that can be deployed what I
will say to you is again in in any case
no individual no patient will proceed
forward unless his or her doctor has
advised of the procedure and it is
considered by the FDA and others who
have to go ahead and certify a medicine
or a procedure to be safe and effective
so I'll try to distill it into a more
simple Farm in what case would it be
appropriate to perform irreversible sex
change surgery on kids
those decisions are made by that
individual in consultation with
physician and caregivers and no decision
would be made without having consulted
appropriately
the decision will be made by the kids
hold on I thought the whole point of
kids is that they can't make decisions
they can't give consent that's why we
have consent laws that's why we say that
a 16 year old
can't consent to have a one-night stand
because that kind of a sexual decision
is is too great and we as a society have
decided that we should not allow 16 year
olds to make that kind of decision and
yet we're going to make if we're not
going to allow a 16 year old to make a
fleeting sexual decision why would we
allow a six-year-old to make a permanent
irreversible sexual decision it doesn't
make a lot of sense
but it's it's actually the same issue
that Bronte was talking about at the top
of the show
I was so happy that that Bronte didn't
just focus on consent or straw man
arguments because she got down to the
heart of it which is autonomy so it's
what I want to do it's my will we've
focused our entire Politics on will I
want
okay you're even seeing this in some of
the reaction to the Supreme Court right
now why are we listening to the Supreme
Court we have the power we have the
let's just just knock down the Supreme
Court let's burn this thing to the
ground that's what people are saying
because they're pursuing a politics of
pure will divorced from logic and
divorced from reality and that that's
not good
so when we do that I want to be as
charitable as I can as Xavier Becerra
maybe he's a groomer maybe he's a creep
maybe he's a weirdo but probably he's
not he's probably just deluded and he's
probably just in the thrall of this
ideology that says that all that matters
is our own exercise of the will and
little kids and little babies create a
problem for this because they do not
have fully developed Wills they do not
they they cannot really exercise their
autonomy whatsoever and we have a
responsibility to restrain our autonomy
and our desires so that we can take care
of those children that's that's the
difference between a politics that's
entirely about rights and entitlement
and a politics that recognizes that no
we're not born free-floating atoms that
actually were born with responsibilities
and Duty and were born into a family and
into a legal community
and into a political community
we have responsibilities especially to
kids which brings up the the most
important National Saga of course
Kim Kardashian and Kanye West and Ray J
and the sex tape this story has been
floating around
really for 15 years now but it's come
back up in the news these Kim Kardashian
is plugging a new show
and what Kim Kardashian said was that
her son was looking on the computer and
saw an ad pop-up for new scenes from Kim
Kardashian's sex tape
and she came out and made a big news
story out of this and said I'm being
victimized again and I was already
victimized when the tape was leaked so
many years ago and I'm the victim of
revenge porn or something like that and
now there's new stuff and there was this
whole long Saga and uh Kim Kardashian's
co-star in the sex tape just came out
and said that is not what really went
down
I did not I'm not the bad guy here I did
not secretly leak this tape actually Kim
you and I agreed to release this tape
and your mother brokered the deal and
we've all been business partners on this
tape for 15 years and we're still making
money on it that was his argument again
I don't I don't know exactly who's
telling the truth here but there have
have been rumors for a long time that
Kim Kardashian was in on this because
she saw that Paris Hilton sex tape made
her a big star and so there was a
planned release of the sex date before
Kim Kardashian's TV show
regardless of what really happened here
this is awful for the kids this is awful
it's awful to put kids in this situation
it's awful to put your whole personal
life on television all the time for
years and years for everyone to see it's
awful if the story is true that Mrs
Kardashian what's her Kris Jenner pimped
out her daughter to make some money that
that would be very sad if that is true
and it would be much better if we just
didn't allow this stuff
okay what if what what then
what what the the overruling the
potential overruling of Roe versus Wade
is showing us is that we actually have a
lot of rights in the political Community
when a bunch of Rogue lawyers on the
Supreme Court don't take our rights away
when a bunch of robed technocrats in the
CDC and the NIH like Dr fauci don't take
all of our rights away we the people
have a lot of Rights there are
boundaries set by the Constitution but
they're relatively limited and then we
the people can kind of decide how we
want to live what if we passed a law
that said hey no porn porn is illegal
we've had laws like that in this country
before what if if we passed a law that
said hey no more porn Kim Kardashian
wouldn't have to worry about her kid
finding her sex tape ads on the internet
almost certainly wouldn't have to be
much much harder to distribute that sort
of thing furthermore we wouldn't have
the Kardashians can you imagine how
great that would be that's that's what
I'm going to run on when I when I try to
pass this bill okay no more weird
internet sex tape porn stuff I'm gonna
get out there and I'm going to say my
strongest argument is had we had this
law in place in 2007 and we wouldn't be
subjected to the plague of the
Kardashians in all of their TV shows and
all of all of their tawdry culture what
if we just did that we can do that
we have the right and Anna kasparian can
cry about it and lots of Libs can cry
about how we have the right to set our
own Community standards here but we do
okay and we have to do it someone's
going to set it either it's going to be
the radicals or it's going to be us what
if we say no more no more chopping off
the genitals of the little kids no more
cross-sex hormones for seven-year-olds
we can do that what if we said no more
transgender surgery for anyone because
it's wrong and it harms everybody and it
helps nobody we can do that we can do
that we have political power if we are
willing to exercise it okay we got to
talk about really tangible things here
when you when you talk about
the digital world whether you're talking
about digital sex tapes or anything else
there was a a video that went viral
about a week ago that I loved so much
everyone was making fun of the girls in
this video I thought they made a great
point the question was if I offered you
right now one Bitcoin or a hundred
dollar bill which would you take
100 cash or a Bitcoin okay what would
you rather take
cash or a Bitcoin I gotta say 100 cash a
hundred dollars cash every single time
why why Bitcoin is a little fake to me
not gonna lie I first of all don't know
what Bitcoin is second of all it seems
like a scam like it's at forty thousand
dollars
what is that dollars what are we getting
we're getting straight dollars like a
hundred dollars cash in my hand feels
way more tangible and way more real than
like Bitcoin
I don't know what Bitcoin is now I know
these girls are totally wrong and
misguided except they're obviously right
yes it's true today a Bitcoin is worth
whatever 40 Grand or something and the
100 is a hundred dollars but the point
they're making which is that Bitcoin
seems kind of scammy and fake and weird
and not very tangible that's obviously
true I say this to someone I've lost
money on cryptocurrencies because I
thought oh this would be a fun kind of
currency goes up and down and up and
down and it's really just a speculative
asset at this point unfortunately
because of Joe Biden's inflation the
hundred dollar bill isn't worth very
much anymore either but it does seem
more tangible and and Beyond this sort
of silly viral video where the girls
were supposed to pick the Bitcoin but
they said no I actually want something
tangible this gives us an important
lesson about politics
offer voters something tangible
the the American people are rebelling
against the virtual reality that the
libs are trying to stuff on us the
telecommuting and the stay in your pod
and don't own anything and you'll be
happy and the transgenderism and the
transhumanism people are rebelling
against that you're seeing in Virginia
you're seeing it in Florida you're
seeing it all around the country the
arguments that are going to win the day
on abortion are just looking at the baby
Hey look it's a baby you shouldn't kill
babies that's a bad idea
don't
don't get in your own head don't clench
defeat from the jaws of Victory don't
get lost Pie in the Sky offer people
tangible stuff when we're looking ahead
to the midterms when we're looking ahead
to 2024. hey we need cheaper gas hey we
need cheaper food hey we need to protect
your kids from weirdos in schools leave
the the crazy bizarre virtual reality
metaverse theories to the libs that is
not popular people want Cold Hard Cash
and cold hard reality I'm Michael
knowlesist Michael Knowles show see you
tomorrow
foreign
[Music]
show is produced by Ben Davies executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer Mathis Glover production
manager Pavel vidovsky editor and
Associate producer Danny D'Amico
associate producer Justine Turley audio
mixer Mike coromina and hair and makeup
by Cherokee heart Michael Knoll show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2022. today on the Ben Shapiro show
not a single major Democrat will condemn
the league of a supreme court opinion
over turning robe Joe Biden says the
Trump base is the most extreme political
organization in American history and the
Federal Reserve boosts interest rates a
full Half Point as today on the Ben
Shapiro show give it a listen